[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Now let's talk
about our guest author.
So we have Bonnie Rochman.
She's a graduate of the
University of North Carolina
at Chapel Hill.
She's a Seattle local currently.
And an award-winning
health and science writer.
Her work has appeared in
Time magazine, Time.com, O,
that's the Oprah Magazine,
Parenting, Babble, DX, Slate,
Cookie, and the
News and Observer.
She's here today to talk
about her first book, which
came out one week ago.
It's "The Gene Machine:
How Genetic Technologies
Are Transforming Parenting
and Reshaping Our Society."
And in this book she
explores the cutting edge
of gene technology and how
it is transforming medicine,
bioethics, health
care, and the factors
that shape our families.
So let's welcome Bonnie Rochman.
[APPLAUSE]
BONNIE ROCHMAN: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for having me.
I want to let you know,
if you're worrying,
Ah, this doesn't
really have that
much to do with my
particular line of work.
Yes, it does.
At its heart, this is
really a story about data.
And I know that
that speaks to you.
So I'm going to
start by telling you
how this book came about it,
which requires me to pull out
this questionable graduation
picture from 1994,
when I graduated from UNC.
It was the bicentennial.
UNC happens to be the nation's
oldest public university.
And we were fully expecting
a really impressive speaker.
So other classes had
gotten Madeline Albright,
Desmond Tutu, John Grisham.
And we heard we were getting
a guy named Francis Collins.
No one knew who he
was at the time.
Oh, there I see a nod there.
At the time, he was director
of the National Human Genome
Research Institute.
What?
No one knew what
that was either.
So his job was to
try to articulate
all three billion
base pairs that
are part of our genome,
our genetic code.
And I have to say, it
seemed incredibly remote.
Nevertheless, Francis
did a bang-up job.
He gave a great speech.
We all went out into the world.
And he did such a good
job that, in 2009,
15 years after graduation,
he was actually
appointed head of the
National Institutes of Health,
or NIH, which is our country's
medical research agency.
That was the same
year that I started
working at Time magazine.
And I was a health and
parenting columnist.
This was my column.
It was called Family Matters.
And I could write about
pretty much anything
I wanted as long
as it intersected
with health and parenting.
So that means I got
to write about Beyonce
and her promotion of
public breastfeeding,
and how friends influence
other friends' decision
to vaccinate or not to
vaccinate their children.
And I found that, left
to my own devices,
I actually wrote quite
a bit about genetics.
So I wrote about some pretty
questionable companies that
were marketing tests
to kind of determine
your child's aptitude
for a particular sport,
you know, kind of
based on their genes.
What they would be particularly
good at, if you want to sort of
steer them in a direction
of a particular sport.
And I wrote about
parents' decisions
to share or not to share
their genetic testing
results with their children.
And I had been doing this
job for about six months
when the study up there
landed in my inbox.
And I remember this
very well, because I
was on a plane with my family
en route to a family vacation.
And my kids, who were three,
six, and eight at the time,
I remember looking
over at them--
and they were all
seated in one row--
and thinking, would
I want to know
this level of data, this depth
of information about my kids?
So what this study was
about the level of--
the information that this
study was looking to find out--
had to do with a
group of parents
who had had genetic testing.
And the parents were
then asked hypothetically
if they would want to test
their kids under the age of 18
for some very common,
adult-onset disorders.
Things like diabetes,
like skin cancer,
like high cholesterol
or high blood pressure.
And the parents pretty much
uniformly, across the board,
said, Yeah.
Totally.
Bring it on.
We're going-- this is
going to be amazing.
We're going to get the
clean bill of health.
We're going to feel like
our kids are super healthy.
And we'll move on.
So what they didn't realize
was that these mutations
are so common that, on average,
each kid would have about nine.
Now not to say they would
definitely get the disease,
but they were at increased
risk for developing
this disease later on.
So what was striking to me is
that people did not understand
the connection between
genes, heredity, disease,
increased risk.
So they were doing this
testing because they
thought they would just
roll things out and feel
really good.
And instead, what
they were going to do
is find information that was
not particularly definitive
but kind of raised
more questions.
And in some cases, it could
actually raise more anxiety.
So that made me realize that
genes are not black and white.
That, in some cases, they're
suggestions about what
will happen down the road.
And in some cases,
they're certainty.
But it's really-- it's
not very cut and dried.
And so there's this
misconception really
that genes are destiny.
But in truth, it's really
just part of the puzzle.
So I was so interested
in these findings,
that genes are not always
destiny, that you really
can't know, that I decided
to look into it more.
So this multi-dimensional aspect
of DNA, of genes, of heredity,
led me to pitch a story
to my editor at Time
about the implications of
sequencing children's genomes,
of reading their
entire genetic code.
And about getting all this data,
all of these huge quantities
of information about
your kids, some of which
will be deterministic, others--
some of the information
won't really--
we won't even really
know what it means.
And is that a good idea?
So it ended up being a series,
a week-long online series.
And then that morphed into a
cover story, the last cover
story of 2012, which you
see up on the screen.
And you know, when you spend a
ton of time on a big project,
you're either--
you never want to hear
another word about it.
Or you're even more intrigued.
So for me it was
the latter, and I
decided to go ahead and write a
book about this world in which
we have more access than ever
to cutting-edge technology,
to peer inside our
genomes, and to emerge
with a snapshot of disease,
both potential and actual.
And I wanted to
do this by telling
the stories of real people.
So speaking of stories of
real people, you may know,
recognize this guy up
there on the screen.
So several years ago, Sergey
Brin did a 23andMe gene panel.
And he learned that he has got
a pretty rare genetic mutation
that predisposes him
to develop Parkinson's.
So I looked up his blog from
when he got his test results,
and he says that when he had
done the genetic testing,
he "viewed it mostly
as entertainment."
And yet what happened
is he ended up
finding this gene mutation
that actually means
he has a significantly elevated
risk of developing Parkinson's
disease.
Now some people in his situation
might feel very freaked out
about that, depending on
what their impressions are
and what their relationship
is with data, especially
personal genetic data.
But Sergey, on the other hand,
he said this in his blog.
He said, "I feel fortunate
to be in this position.
Until the fountain of youth
is discovered, all of us
will have some conditions
in our old age,
only we don't know
what they will be.
I have a better guess
than almost anyone else
for what ills may
be mine, and have
decades to prepare for it."
So that made me think back to
that study that originally set
me off on this entire journey.
And it's really interesting
what Sergey says,
because he is then-- he actually
goes on in his blog to give
specific example of how he might
change his life due to learning
about this genetic mutation
and the predisposition
to Parkinson's.
So there is some
research showing
that exercise may be protective
against the development of /
so I can only imagine that
he has the common gym rat.
He can also direct his money
to help support research Into
causes of Parkinson's,
treatments for Parkinson's.
So I think that his experience
is really illustrative of how
genetic data, even if
it is not a certainty,
really allows you to take
control of your life.
This is Gracie.
She has Down syndrome.
I'll tell you a little bit
more about Gracie in a second.
One way that all this access to
new genetic technology and data
is really changing
our world is that it's
redefining the holy
grail concept of what
it means to be or to
have a healthy baby.
So when you get pregnant,
oftentimes if you ask people,
oh, are you having
a girl or a boy?
They-- sometimes they
have a preference.
But sometimes they'll
just say, I don't care.
I just want a healthy baby.
So what exactly
is a healthy baby.
We have this
constantly expanding
array of genetic technologies
that offer insight prenatally
into a baby's health.
But what does it
mean to be healthy?
For example, a
child, a baby born
with Down syndrome,
about half of the time
they have heart defects
that need surgical repair.
But about half the
time, they don't.
And they can just go
home from the hospital.
So is a baby with Down
syndrome a healthy baby?
Up for debate.
So you know, when I
was born, my mom didn't
know if I had Down syndrome.
She didn't even know
what gender I was.
And today, already in
the first trimester,
there are blood tests
that can detect down
syndrome in a noninvasive way.
Which is really reshaping a lot
of the debate around disability
and the perception of
who should and should not
be born in our society.
So back to Gracie.
She is in Boston, who lives
in Boston, right outside.
And she likes lip
syncing to Taylor Swift.
I visited her two
years ago, and she lip
synced Macklemore's
"Thrift Shop" for me.
She is funny.
She is a diligent learner.
She is doing really
well in school,
thanks to her mom's advocacy,
so she's in inclusion classes.
And she's also really
charmingly irreverent.
One of the funniest
stories in the book
is Gracie's mom telling me about
Gracie's trip to the dentist.
So Gracie-- the dentist
was trying to butter her up
and said to Gracie,
oh, you're so cute.
Can you open your mouth for me?
And Gracie responded, get
away from me, you word
that rhymes with witch.
So a friend of
Gracie's mom joked
that Gracie was really just
saying what everyone else is
thinking anyway.
So there's new research to
improve the lives of people
who have Down syndrome.
There's research into silencing
the extra copy, the extra copy
of the 21st chromosome that
characterizes this condition.
There's research into drugs
that can be taken prenatally
by a pregnant mom or drugs
that can be taken after birth
by a child with Down syndrome.
And as you might
imagine, some parents
are really excited about
this, and some parents
are super conflicted.
And for Melanie, Gracie's mom,
you know, like any parent--
how many of you have kids?
OK, so-- and even for those
of you who don't have kids,
you can imagine-- think
back to your parents.
Everyone always wants
the best for their child.
They want their child to have
every single opportunity.
Yet that really
raises the question
of what does it mean to
have every opportunity.
Are drugs actually
changing the essence
of the child versus helping
them to achieve their potential?
So let's do a quick poll.
I'm going to ask you if it's
good, bad, or inconsequential
to have a baby who is born
blind or missing a limb
or with some sort of
intellectual disability.
Raise your hand if you
think that's a good thing.
What about bad?
Inconsequential?
Doesn't matter at all?
So that's pretty standard.
I've never had anyone
say it's a good thing.
Most people say
it's a bad thing.
And usually a couple of people
say it's inconsequential,
it doesn't really matter
one way or another.
And I interview a professor
of law in the book who--
he researches eugenics, which
is the practice of trying
to build a superior race.
And that is now out of
favor in this country.
It reached its height
during the Nazi era,
but it did go on in
the United States
for many, many, many years.
And this professor,
Paul Lombardo,
he posits that if he would
do a survey of most people
whom he considers compassionate
and not mean spirited,
that most people would
say there are actually
some conditions the baby
should not be born with,
if there is a way to avoid it.
I found really powerful.
Because, you know, we
as a society in general,
we think that we are open
minded, open hearted, and yet,
when it comes right
down to it, if you're
asked about disability,
and you have the option
to opt out of it,
most people say,
no, thanks, in that
sort of situation.
So I spoke with a mom whose
son has something called 22 Q
deletion, which is a condition
in which her son is missing
a small part of his
22nd chromosome.
And it's accompanied
by mild to moderate
intellectual disability.
There can be heart defects.
So this boy in particular
was doing amazingly well
when I interviewed his mom.
He was in a
four-year university.
He was living three
hours away from home.
And still, this mom was
terrified of the possibility
that her son would give
birth to a child like him.
So every year when her son,
who was, I think around 20
at the time, would go for a
check up with his geneticist,
this mom would
beseech the geneticist
to say you have to tell him that
he has to use birth control.
So here you have this
mom who loves her son
and who is really proud
of his accomplishments
and his achievements.
But she's saying, oh, my god,
don't have a kid like you.
So people with 22q have a 50
percent chance of passing that
on to their children.
And this mom is saying, please,
don't give me a grandchild--
don't give me a
grandchild like you.
So you can imagine what kind
of delicate, ethical tightrope
that is to be perched on.
You can actually avoid
22q through something
called preimplantation
genetic diagnosis.
This is a picture up
here of an embryo,
and a couple cells are being
siphoned out of the embryo.
The embryo is just a
few days old, probably
about five days old.
And then those
cells are analyzed
to determine whether
there is the presence
or absence of a particular
genetic mutation.
And so the way that it is
currently used right now
is it's employed, in
most cases, to get rid
of very severe, often
fatal childhood diseases.
Something like Tay-Sachs which
is often fatal before a child
would reach kindergarten.
So you take these embryos--
so you're not-- it's very
different from something
like gene editing.
You probably have all heard
of something called CRISPR,
which is a way to edit genes.
So this is not editing genes.
Instead, this is taking embryos,
looking at them, and saying,
oh, that one has--
that one has Tay-Sachs.
OK, let's discard
that, or let's throw
that-- let's put that aside.
And this one doesn't
have Tay-Sachs.
Let's implant that one
into a woman's uterus.
So you are picking
and choosing, and you
are selecting in favor of not
having a particular disease.
So what's different again,
going back to CRISPR?
CRISPR obviously raises
concerns of what-- you know,
in the media we talk
about designer babies.
What does that really mean?
Well, the truth is that
we don't know currently
how to build a future
Google engineer
or manufacture the next Michael
Jordan or the next Yo-Yo Ma.
And the reason is
because there is not
one single gene that
codes for a killer
jumpshot or amazing ability as
a cellist or as a programmer.
It's a confluence of influences
from your environment, where
you live, who your
parents are, your exposure
to all sorts of things,
plus your genetic makeup.
So PGD is often--
PGD, pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis--
is not as, as you
might imagine, it
is not as an ethically fraught
as something using CRISPR
technology, to edit
genes, to edit embryos.
And it's been used
for decades to avoid
transmitting these serious
diseases, such as Tay-Sachs,
that I mentioned.
But it's also now increasingly
being considered for diseases
that are not quite--diseases
that are not necessarily fatal.
So most people in
this room probably
know someone who's been
diagnosed with breast cancer.
And you can select an
embryo that does not
have a breast cancer mutation.
So if that BRCA1
or BRCA2 mutation
runs in your family, or a whole
host of other breast cancer
mutations, BRCA1 and 2
are just the most common.
So if those run in
your family, and you
want to kind of stop
that train and say,
I don't want to transmit--
you know, this has
been hell in my family.
My mom died.
My aunt died.
I was diagnosed when
I was in my 20s.
And I don't want to pass
this legacy onto my child.
You can do your pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis
to have a child who
has not inherited
your genetic mutation.
So that raises the question
of, are we playing God
by doing something like that?
You know, breast cancer is
very different from Tay-Sachs.
Having a genetic mutation
that predisposes you
to breast cancer just
means that you're
at increased risk for it.
It's like Sergey's Parkinson's.
He won't necessarily get it.
It means he's at
elevated risk for it.
So knowing that someone,
knowing that an embryo
is at elevated
risk for a disease,
is it ethical to
not have that child?
To not bring that child
into the world because
of a possibility
of a disease that
may develop decades
down the road?
Now let's change the scenario
even a little bit more.
Let's say you are
completely opposed
to doing something
like that, to using
pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis
and that data to weed
out certain embryos.
But let's say you have a breast
cancer mutation in your family.
And you have a baby.
Do you then think that
you have the right to data
to know whether your
child has inherited
your genetic mutation?
So pediatric ethics
guidelines say, no, you don't.
You don't have the right to
know-- you don't have the right
to test your child
under the age of 18
unless it's medically necessary.
And something like knowing
about a risk for breast cancer
would not be considered
medically necessary
for a three-month old.
So I'm going to read
to you a little bit
from the book of, even something
like this, how complicated it
can be.
So the first little bit
I'm going to read to you
is from a doctor
named Mike Bamshad.
He is the head of pediatric
genetic medicine at you UW.
And he says, we are
recommending that parents
be left with the ambiguity
that their infant is
at higher risk for breast
cancer because they
have breast cancer
in their family
but were unwilling to test
the baby to know for sure.
He disagrees with
that, and he says,
if we're counseling
someone in clinic,
and they're at high
risk for breast cancer,
and they have their
infant daughter with them,
why in the world we wait to
talk again until she's 18?
Why would we not test and
say, she's not a BRCA carrier,
or she is.
And here's what you
should do about it.
We should use this
information, this data,
to improve health care.
And one of the clearest
ways to improve health care
is to prevent disease.
It's very clear cut.
So I find that
incredibly persuasive.
And then I'm going
to read to you
a passage from a woman who
became my friend after I
interviewed her.
She was diagnosed with
breast cancer at age 32.
Her mom died when
she was very young.
And she has a BRCA mutation.
So this is Debbie, right after
she found out via ultrasound
that she was having a daughter
I came out saying, oh, my god,
what if she gets breast cancer?
Her husband, Evan,
did not understand.
He calls me doom and gloom.
But I said, I'm going to die
if she gets breast cancer.
Debbie was determined
to find a way
to test her daughter,
Jordan, but her husband
was adamantly opposed.
And now she agrees with him.
I don't think it's fair for
us to have that information
and have that
heaviness in our family
or in how we relate to Jordan.
I think knowing whether
Jordan is positive or negative
would also cause a lot
of tension and sadness
in our family.
When you think about
testing your child,
you have to think
of the ramifications
that it would have on
lots of family members.
So you can see two very
well-reasoned, yet extremely
different, perspectives
on the value
and the appropriateness
of information.
It's really super complicated.
As the technology evolves,
these ethical dilemmas
are coming at us
fast and furious.
I'm not a scientist.
I like to think of
myself as a humanist.
And I wrote this book
because I'm really
fascinated by these
questions of right or wrong.
And red lines.
Are there red lines?
Are there are red lines?
Where are they?
Who decides?
And nowhere is this
more heated than when
it comes to making babies.
Again we have to just keep
asking ourselves the question,
and as Google Earth, I'm
sure you can appreciate that,
Is there such a thing
as too much information?
So these are all
really big ideas.
I don't give yes or
no answers, because I
don't believe there are none.
I think these decisions
are all extremely personal.
They're individual.
And it really comes
down to choice
and what's right for
you and your comfort
with a great degree of
information and data.
So if you're sick of small
talk at your next party,
you can try these
topics on for size.
Do parents have a right to all
of their child's health data?
So some experts believe that
within a couple of years,
we're going to have our
genome in the cloud.
So if parents-- if
that does come to pass,
should parents know
everything there
is to know about a child's DNA?
And let's say that
there's a problem.
Would you love your kid
less or maybe even more?
Now back to that BRCA mutation.
Say your newborn has
her genome sequenced,
and a BRCA mutation
is discovered.
You know, a couple
minutes ago, I
told you that, well, pediatric
ethics guidelines say
that we don't test.
We don't test kids
under 18 for something
that is not medically
necessary and needs
to be dealt with right now.
But it's really
likely that that baby
has inherited her
genetic mutation
from her mom or her dad.
And let's say those
parents don't know
that they have the mutation.
So by telling them,
you then are enabling
them to take whatever measures
they feel are appropriate.
A mom could have a
prophylactic mastectomy.
A dad could-- men obviously
get breast cancer as well.
They're also at greater
risk for prostate cancer.
So you're just
basically enabling
them to be more empowered
regarding their own health.
And you know, it's
really complicated,
because you think
that you're not
supposed to tell the
parents because you're
sort of encroaching
upon the child,
you know, the child's right
of privacy and protecting
her own genetic data.
And yet, telling the parents
that the child has a mutation
could actually be
a way, clear way,
to do something really
amazing for that child
by potentially averting the
death of one of her parents.
So in short, it used to be
a lot easier to be pregnant.
As I said, my mom did not even
know if I was a boy or a girl
when I was born.
And today we have tons
and tons of genetic data.
We often-- I won't say
often, but regularly,
as the tests get
more sophisticated,
we'll find out information
that is completely unclear.
And you have to
then decide, do you
proceed with this
pregnancy based on really
uncertain information?
I spin the stories
of several families
who got really
disconcerting information,
like their baby was missing
a couple genes or some DNA
was duplicated, and what
exactly does that mean?
And how do you
proceed with that?
In some of these
cases, the parents
learned that they actually
had the same deletions
or genetic duplications.
And then, it's
pretty mind blowing.
You have to figure out how
to process all of that.
So I'm going to end with--
I'm going to end with
the best compliment
that I received about
this book, which
is going entail me
telling you a little bit
about the book-building process
and these impressive blurbs
that appear on the back.
I feel like Vanna White up here.
So you know, these blurbs
don't just appear there.
It's not like someone goes into
a bookstore, reads my book,
and is just so incredibly moved
that they contact my publisher
and say, I've got to
write some words of praise
for the back of
that lady's jacket.
No.
Instead, it's this very arduous
process of reaching out to--
so I convened with my
editor, and we kind of
developed a list of
really influential people
who would be amazing to
blurb the back of the book.
And then it's this very
humiliating process
of reaching out via
email and basically
begging these people who
are already incredibly
busy to please read your book
and, if they're so inclined,
and if they like
it, maybe they'll
write a couple of pithy words
for you to stick on the jacket.
So one of these women,
Kelley Benham French,
had just written her own book,
a really beautiful memoir
about the birth of her
extremely premature daughter.
The book is called "Juniper."
And I had-- she had agreed to
receive a copy of the book.
And so I followed up for
the first time on October 26
by writing to her and saying,
Hey, just checking in.
You know, trying to
remain all casual.
And she responded,
Just got the book
and haven't looked at it yet.
But I'm looking forward to it.
So I wrote back, Ugh, isn't this
blurb seeking just the worst.
I appreciate your making
the effort, Kelley.
And the next day,
she wrote back,
The whole book promotion thing.
Ugh, standing naked
on the street corner
would be more fun.
So I decided I was
going up the ante here.
More like standing naked
on the street corner
in subzero temps
in Times Square.
That would only being
to capture the horror.
And then she went radio silent
on me after I bared my soul.
So I decided to check
in after a week.
Hello, fellow naked
street corner dweller.
I'm gritting my teeth, and
oh, so casually checking in,
to see if you just might
be inclined to blurb
this book of mine.
Time dragged by.
There was no word.
And then finally I
got an email from her.
10 words total.
This book doesn't suck.
Thank god.
That would have been awkward.
I laughed, and I
wrote back to her,
That is the blurb right there.
This book doesn't suck.
And then she
responded, you can see,
we had a great email
correspondence going.
And she really
had the last word.
She wrote, Really, that's all
any of us can ever hope for.
So I find that--
it wasn't just about my book.
That's really a universal truth.
So I hope you enjoyed
hearing about the book.
And I hope you find
it interesting.
I hope it makes you think about
things that you hadn't really
considered before.
About science and babies
and how these two things
intersect in ways both
marvelous and mysterious.
And thank you so
much for coming.
I'm happy to take any questions.
SPEAKER: Yeah, so I mean,
we can debate the ethics
and have a lot of
philosophical arguments.
But at the end, either
technology will work
or it won't, right?
So you know, when little
Johnny goes to school,
if little Alice, who had
genetic modification,
is better than
him in everything,
then when Johnny has a brother
or sister, if the parents can
afford it, they're
going to do it, right?
BONNIE ROCHMAN: Well, not
speaking for Johnny's parents,
but the important thing to
note is that currently, we
don't know how to make
so-called designer babies.
In fact, in the book, I talk
about, well, in some ways,
we're actually already
creating designer babies.
If anyone here has
had a child via IVF
or know someone who has,
and it's everywhere now.
Those babies could
actually technically
be considered designer babies.
So if you're
choosing donor sperm,
you go through this
entire checklist.
You can learn where the
donor went to school.
What the donor's job is.
What the donor's
personality is like.
You can access baby pictures.
You know, it's basically like
this whole smorgasbord of trays
there.
You know, the donor
has a quick temper.
The donor has an
amazing sense of humor.
And you can select
all these things.
But you know, I think it can
be argued that already we're
doing that.
And people who have--
who go through
assisted reproduction,
but if you're just having
sex the regular way,
the way that we've done for
centuries, we just don't--
you can't.
It's luck of the draw.
And even if you then
apply technologies
through assisted
reproduction, we
don't know how to make
the next Einstein.
So it's a whole--
you know, it's kind of, if
someone could crack the code,
then I think that your question
would be a lot more valid.
But currently, we don't know.
There's not one-- there's
not the intelligence gene.
And the
awesome-on-the-football-field,
you know, Seattle Seahawks gene.
So it's just not-- it's not
possible at this point in time.
It's really focused more
on disease and elimination
of disease.
SPEAKER: Well, thank you
very much for telling us
about your book
that doesn't suck.
BONNIE ROCHMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]